طلبوا حضوري
ايش السبب قالوا احنا من سنتين نتابعك
واللوغو حقك مثير
مثير للجنس
قال قلت له يا اخي انا اللي اعرف الاسلام
دينوفو حضاره يعني معقول لوجو يطير رجل
الدين طب ليش شاف البنطلون ايش يصير
[موسيقى]
هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن ابو
مالح جدي كان خياط وله مكان انت في القريه
وكان يفصل الملابس للرجال والنساء في
القريه بعد سنوات صار ابن اخوه مصمم ازياء
عالمي لكن الغريب هنا هو رده فعل القريه
المختلفه تماما اتجاه القسطتين من قبول
ومكانه الى رفض نفس
اكيد انه التغيرات المستمعيه في ابها اثرت
على تقبول الفكره بين هذين بس ايش تغير
المجتمع بين هاتين الفترهتين المهم من
ناحيه تاريخيه وتحليليه لكن من سيره ذاتيه
في هذه الحلقه هي سيره ذاتيه من ابن
القريه الى مصمم ازياء يشارك في اسبوع
الموضه في باريس ويصمم للاميره ديانا
والملك تشارلز والملك عبد الله بن عبد
العزيز
كيف
هذه التغيرات المجتمعيه وكيف في هذه
التحديات داخل العائله ومع الدوله من مجال
الازياء من التسعينات حتى يومنا هذا مع
ضيفي يحيى البشري اول مصمم ازياء سعودي
والحلقه تتجاوز السيره الذاتيه للحديث عن
الثياب والعبايات فادرك ان الازياء في
السعوديه تهمنا كلنا الكل يهتم في شكل
وتصميم ثوب وشماغه والجاكيت وطريقه اللباس
والنساء اليوم صارت العبايه جزء مهم من
الشكل والاناقه الازياء في السعوديه يعتبر
اهم سوق في الوطن العربي يقدر السوق بقيمه
18 مليار واليوم في اهتمام اكبر من اي وقت
سابق يشوف مصممات يدخلون السوق بقوه طبعا
عند ابو ريان تحفظ على هذا الموضوع واليوم
كذلك صار عندنا هيئه للازياء والدعم لم
يسبق له مثيل قبل ان نبدا شاركونا اسماء
ضيوف او مواضيع تقترحونها على فنجان على
بريد البرنامج فنجان 8 دوت كوم
الان
لنبدا
حلو والله معموله
يوتيوب البدايات يعني
ثمان سنوات اول مره اخرج من قريه عمري
ثمان سنوات وكان
ااا كان الغريب في الخروج انه
كان عندي شيء بخرج من مكان اصغر شيء اكبر
ولقيت الفرصه انه ابوي بيروح يزور اخوي
وانه اخذني معه
وكان اول مره اشوف تليفزيون
بالنسبه لي حاجه ناس يمشوا في
شاشه كانت
صدمه كبيره يعني
ممكن انا اسمي هذه الصدمه الاولى اللي خلت
معاد عندي ارجع القريه يعني كيف اقنعه اني
اقعد وحتى لما رجعت يعني
طبعا لما تروح على مكان
في الحياه اخرى ما عاد تكذب بالمكان
الصغير
واحده من الصدمات لكن الشيء الغريب انه
مراقبه القصيره 10 سنين في القريه او شيء
ما اعرف ايش الذاكره العجيبه في هذا
القريب ما نسيت ولا اي شيء من هذا
التفاصيل لا في اللهجه
تصرفات لا في الحياه انا مرسومه وبعدين
يصير لي شيء ثاني كل ما احلم بشيء حتى لو
عرض ازياء في فرنسا يبدا من هذا البيت
اللي في القريه اللي كنت بحسبه بيتنا كبير
وبعدين لما مره زرت القريه
يعني شيء يعني صغير صغير بس انه سالت كم
واحد على ايش الموضوع
فهذا يعني السر انه كان في هذا الفتره
صحيح هذا القريه كانت جميله
مكنه انت بتشدد ما كانوا متالفين مع بعض
كان يحبوا الحياه كان يحبوا الغنى كانوا
الجنوبيين او القرويين غنوا من الصباح الى
المساء
في الزرع يعني غناء معين اللي يرعى له
غناء ثاني الحريم اللي يجيبونه الحطب لهم
غناء النساء اللي يجيبوا المويه من البئر
لهم هنا واللي يعملون في البناء يبنون لهم
كمان طريقه فكانت وبعدين في الليل يبداوا
في هذا الظلام لانه ما في كهرباء يسوون
طرق في الليل ويغنوا من شباك لشباك على
بعضه طبعا كانت ما في شكله جميله بس كنت
تحتاج فضاء او ساعه هذا اللي كان عندي
رجعتني اربع شهور ثلاثه شهور بس بعدين
كملت
حياتي كلها تقريبا
في الدعايه عشت فيها لين همم لين جاءت همم
مصادفه الموضه هذه لما جاءت المصادفه هي
اا بسعر حياتي بره اكثر من السعوديه يعني
خليني ارجع الحين
يعني بس انه واحد يطلع من الديره الى جده
يعني هل الوالد كان اوكي معها اخوي كنت
عايش مع اخوي فما كان عنده مشكله لا
وبعدين في الجنوب يبغى ان همم يطلع همم
يبغى يشتغل حتى شغله من الاولى
[موسيقى]
الفكره التعليميه يعني ظروفهم ما كانت
جيده
والصعوبات هذه تخليكم انه ما يهمهم انك
تبدا حياتك انك تساعدنا يعني هذه واحده من
اهدافها
درس الابتدائي
في المتوسط برده في القريه
واذا القريه كانت بالنسبه لك يعني كانت
يعني
حياه سعيده
[موسيقى]
تغير بشكل عجيب يعني ما عدا اصبح اهل
القريه الجميلين هذول المتالفين اللي
يحبوا بعض صارت عوازل حواجز بينهم سير
الاخ ما يشوفوا
ما عاد تشوف العائله مع بعضهم كل واحد
متفرج فما ما عاد صارت تجذبني كانت
باطارده اكثر
بس الحين احس الناس كثير من اللي صار هل
فعلا كانت زمان غير اللي انت تقوله
انا طلعت
انا دخلت جدا جدا
والمراه المتزوجه المسطرحه
فخلاص معروف هذه وكلنا مع بعض يروحوا
يشتغلوا المويه من البير هم اللي يجيبوا
الحطب وكان في الجنوب في القريه حالتين
خارج البيت للرجل وداخل البيت للمراه حتى
في التزيين يعني في القطه في العمل داخل
البيت كل هالمره اللي تسويه خارج البيت اي
شيء خارج البيت سواء منه الزراعه او من
الاهتمام الخارجي
حلو كان جميل
ما ما في عندهم هذا
همم التباعد اللي شفته بعد كده يعني
تغيروا شكل عجيب
فجاه وانا حضرت وحده من هذه يعني كان
عندنا السوق اسمه سوق الاثنين هذا مشهور
عندنا كل اثنين في القريه في هذا السوق
وفجاه جابوا برميل وطلع عليه واحد لابس
مشلح وهذه اول مره نشوفها في ال و ينصحهم
انه لازم تغطوا على الغطاء والحمو ما ادري
ايش شكله وكان في هذا الفتره معه كيف
تطهير
وسارت احداث كثيره
مع الوقت بداوا اعتقد انه لما تغيروا
بداخلوا هذا والصح اعتقد انه انا دائما
اختلف مع مع كثير ناس في الجنوب انهم
يقولوا ان الجنوب كانت متحضره اكثر بينهم
كانوا مع بعض وما عرفاش طب كيف تغيروا في
هذا اللحظه السريعه يعني انا رحت عشت في
جده رسميه مدينه ممانعه ما رضيوا ما قبله
هذا الافكار طيب كيف سيطروا في الجنوب
بسرعه
معناته في فيلم
يقول لك فكك النص كيف فانا لما همم شفتهم
هذا يعني اتكلم معه كثير الجنوبيه
انه كان السبب الاحتياج هذا اللي خلاهم
يعملوا كده ولكن داخلهم
ااا اضطهاد للمراه والدليل انه اول ما
جاءت الصحوه والمسك العصر المسك المفاتيح
بيدهم السيطره عليها سيطر كامله وكانهم
كانوا يمنوا نفس هذا الفتره والدليل انه
كانوا يقولوا حاجتين دائما الحريم ياكلوا
بعدهم هذا احتقار
وكانوا المراه ما تولد
في المزارع وكان الرجل لما ينزل يقول معي
زوجتي الله يعزك
فاذا كان احتقار وهم يدعوا انهم كانوا
متحضرين ولكن انه عشان الاحتياج انه يبغى
يجيب المويه
بدات الحياه ولده يشتغلوا الاولاد
اللي ينادي بانه تفصل المراه تماما عن
الرجل كانت بالنسبه لهم سعاده اعتقد انهم
كانوا يتمنوا هذا الشيء همم
سيطر موقف بسرعه بسرعه تغيره
في وقتها الحين انت خلصت رحت جده الثانويه
[موسيقى]
بعدين
بدات مع
يعني مع مع السعودي زيت من عمري 18 سنه
وبعدين كان صديق لي اسمه مصطفى ادريس الله
يرحمه في عكاظ اقنعني اني اكتب بالعربي
والكتابه بالانجليزيه تختلف عن العربيه
العربيه لازم ننشر جاكشن او المقدمات
والهذه
الكتابه الانجليزيه مباشره
بدات معهم في عكاظ
[موسيقى]
ودعت الجامعه وفي نفس الوقت كنت اسوي شغل
بزنس او يعني نبغى اعمل شيء لكن
هميولي الكتاب او الشعر
والحوارات
وحتى يعني كتبت مقالات اجتماعيه مقالات بس
كان كل كتابتي اكثر عن الفن يعني وحتى انا
اتذكر انه مره انه مقاله اني كتبت يعني
لانه غذاء الروح هي الموسيقى
فكان كتبت صادم في بعض
وفي حتى الدراسه في فرنسا انا كملت
كتابه مقالات يعني جزء من
الداخل اللي اسويه هو من كثافه المقالات
اللي كنت اكتبها العقاب ايش اللي يخلي
ميولك الفنيه موجود
في العالم الثالث ما تكتشف نفسك ممكن تكبر
وتكون موهوب وتموت موهبتك معادك لانه ما
في
العلاقه العائليه اللي اللي يشوفوا ولدهم
او بنتهم فين اتجاهها حتى لو لقوا في
ولدهم وبنتهم
من البدايه هذا موجود في العالم الثالث
بفكر فني انك تكون
حتى كتابه شعر كانت يعني غير مقبوله في
فتره معينه انه ليه المعلومات انت هتجيء
مع المطربين وهذا ودائما في نظرتهم كانت
الدهيمه في العالم الثالث انه هذول بويه
يمين ويعيشوا حاله مزريه وما يكون عندهم
دخلوا
وبحيفضحنا والعار يعني كلها صفات غريبه
يعني اا يعني المجتمع اعطاها يعني
واحه من الناس
كثير ما هو بس في هذا الشيء كان حياتنا
كلها وهم اذا كانت قياده المراه وهم اذا
كانت السينما وهم اذا كان اي شيء فيه
سعاده او حب وهم
لازم تبعد عنه
فانا اقول انه يعني
في العالم الثالث
في لبسهم في معظم حياتهم اذا هذا اللي ايش
يقولوا علينا الناس دائما حتى في المجال
الفني او المجال
الابداعي لو دخلته برضه يفكروا في الناس
اكثر ما يفكروا في ساعات انك تحب شيء
يعني اعتقد الحمد لله اكثر شيء انا حررت
اولادي من هذا الموضوع فكان هذه يعني
سعاده لانه اني طبقت ال ال اللي قابلتهم
مشاكل حررت انه يختار واحد الدروس اللي
تحبه طيب على ال- ال-
الفكره الفرنسي انك تفكك الاشياء حاولت
تفكك ليش انت همم
مختلف اللي اهتم بالفن اكثر من اي شيء
ثاني
شوف انا اؤمن القراءه لها دور كبير في
الحياه انا من صغري يعني عاشق القراءه ما
اعرف كيف كنت اقرا ال 45 كتب في الشهر
والى زلت الان هذا القراءه دائما هي تغيرت
الانسان تفضحك على اشياء كثيره في كل منا
داخل شيء بس انه ما هو عارفه يمكن انا
عرفت نفسي انه فيني شيء ولكن عارف اني حد
صادم مشاكل بس هل حصمت او لا اه لو ما كنت
انا عاشق للموضه ما اعتقد الصمد قبل يعني
اكثر من 20 مره وقفوني وسجنوني تقريبا فلو
لو لو ما انا عاشق لهذا الشيء خلاص مره
مرتين ثلاث مرات هذا كله وراحوا منه ما حد
عاجبه لا من اهلك انهم يعتبرونه انك يعني
ايش اللي بتسويه حتى لو حتى اتصال فيهم
قال يعني بارك لهم شيء هم ما يبغوا
يسمعونه كل هذا معناته انا كان عندي عشق
يعني كان عدم مخبا هذا العشق موضع ولما
عرفتها انفجر
همم يعني كنت انا اسمي على شان كده تقول
هذه المجال الفرنسيه ليمون تقول انه في
هذا المجتمعات ممكن الواحد يصير اي شيء
لكن مثلا تصبح ثم ازياء اكيد عينيها
الكثير
لانه لما تكون في مكان متشدد من اهلكم
مجتمعك وهذا متسويه
حتى حتى في صناعته بره يعني انت لما انا
اذكر انه اول عرض عملته في حياتي كان عرض
انتحار يعني لا يمكن لا يمكن تسويه هذا
العرض يعني انك تدخل الاسبوع الماضي
الفرنسي عن 90 وانت غير ما انت يعني معروف
ولا عندك الامكانات
كيف يدخل سعودي في الموضوع
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوشن سبايسي
[موسيقى]
طيب متى اول مره
بالنسبه لك والازياء
يعني
في راسي هو النقوش
الجنوبيه النقوش القطه اللي همم
فن جميل
ورغم
امكانياتهم ضعيفه يعني
تقط كيف كانت تشيع عندنا في البيت والجدار
معروج يعني تعرف ما هو مستقيم وهي ما
عندها لمسطره ولا شيء وكيف تعمل هذا
الادوات الصغيره هذا الفن الجميل يمكن هذا
هو اللي موجود في راسي
وطبعا لبسهم اللبس في الجنوب
كان يسوي رجال اللي خيط ثياب رجال فيروح
عند العائله
ويقعد عندها 20 يوم او 25 يوم لين يخلص
يشكوا باليد اي فصل الرجال
[موسيقى]
بصراحه كنت اروح عند عشان اشوف
بنات يعني يعني واحد شاب واروح عنده عشان
دائما يجون البنات وكان اعتاد اللغه
المتواجده هذيك الايام
وكنت ارسم اشياء
عملتها كده ليش ما تعملها كده ليش كلام
انا جالس مره
تعال ضروري في عندي شيء
انا ولا ولا حاجه ولا عمره خطف بالي حكايه
الموضه طبعا ما هي موجوده في راسي اصلا
فقال لي جاء واحد ايطالي مشترى رسوماتك ب
راجل يشوفك
شفت واحد ايطالي
علم كامل لانه صناعه كامله اييه يعني حتى
للاسف الناس دائما انا في الموضه ما
يعجبني انه يقول واحد انه كل واحد ما في
شيء اسمه في علم وهي علم كبير بنت تتكلم
على صناعه فيها مليارات يعني ممكن ما ادري
اعتقد انا ما اعرف رقمي
ثاني او ثالث
صرف او ال ال دخل او مستروات تقريبا
اجيب لك الرقم اللي في السعوديه
لا لا نسبه الصرف على الازياء
هي نفس اللي ممكن في نفس اليوم تنتج
قطاع الازياء السعودي يقدر الان 18 مليار
وحجم سوق الازياء في السعوديه 70% من سوق
الشرق الاوسط
ضخم جدا
ههه
فاضل اخير يهتم كيف شكله جاءت هذا الفكره
ورجعت عيش هنا يجي لك التمرد هل انت داخلك
تبرد ولا لا يعني هو لعب راسي بالفكره بس
انا عاشق للسفر
[موسيقى]
بس بس
مثلا تنوره
خطين كده حتى الخطوط الخطوط
ما فيها اي بروفيشن ما فيها اي تناسب كلها
فوق يعني بس وهميه لها معنى
اغير شيء لكن ما كان ما كانت فكره انه
مستقبلي ولا انا حياتي الجديده
لون ايش اسمه
22 سنه مديون ب 2 مليون عمرك
ليش ما جاوبوا حلو طيب كيف اجربه لازم
تسافر لازم تروح عند اهلي
هو المحرك اللي كان الله يرحمه مصطفى
ادريس
والله
[موسيقى]
ممكن قال انا ما اقدر اقول لك تنجح بس
ممكن
شيء غريب وشيء جديد
لا 85
المهم
تطلع لك خرجنا من الصدمه الحضاريه الاولى
حق التلفزيون
[موسيقى]
محرك حلو يعني ما ما ما اظن احد الوالد لا
لا لا انسى الموضوع الموضوع والد مين
لا انا قلت في البدايه خليني اشوف
الموضوع طبعا ابوي ما كان يحب السفر حقي
اني دائما اسافر كثير اه فكانت تسافر
اثنين مليون
[ضحك]
بس ما في داعي اقول له الموضوع خليني اشوف
انا رايح اكتشف الواحد
يعني بس خليني اسافر
اه
اذا طبعا ما عندي الصدمه من البلد
الايطالي
[موسيقى]
لما اخذني على ميلانو سكول
كانت
الصدمه اول مره في حياتي اشوف عالم زي كده
طريقه التعليم طريقه
انا انا نفسي بالموضوع وكيف ادخل في
الموضوع
اتلفت حواليني بس على المشهد هذا بس نقعد
سته شهور
من 15 يوم سته شهور
سته شهور في الاكاديميه
لازم تعلمه ايطالي اما كان في الفلوس
اكاديميه في باريس اكاديميه امريكيه
فرنسيه تدرس بالانجليزي
التكني كان كل اللي للجسم للقص للباترون
فيه اكثر من يعني طبعا انا اخذت في هذه
الفتره انت تختار من الكورسات اللي تقدر
تاخذه يعني فاخترت اكثر اولا كنت اكره
حاجه انه لا يوصلوني انه كلمه خياط اني
اعرف اخيط ما بغت ادخل في هذا اللاين انا
دخلت مصمم ابغى شيء اعلى كانت عندي صراع
مع هذا الموضوع يكتشف انه لازم تعرف هذا
الشيء اذا ما عرفت البيسك حقه ما هتعرف
تسويه اه ما رضيت الفكره تركب في راسي
فاخذت دائما انا اخذت الكورسات الرسم طبعا
اخذته تعليم الالوان كانت مهمه همم
بنيت الجسم
في الاخير فالجسم جسم انت تضيف له جماله
وانت شوهوه فلازم يكون عندك العلم الكامل
كيف الطريقه اللي تعمل معه وفي الاخير هي
نسب هي كان دراسه هندسه معماريه او شيء ما
تقدر تبني بيت ما تعرف الكتل والاسمنت نفس
الشيء انت بتبني شايف البناء هذا تحتاج
انك تعرف كل المقاومه يعني هذا اللي اخذته
في البدايه
وطبعا بعد كده لما همم رحت على فرنسا
اختلفت الدراسه
مع نفسي
من اصحابي اللي كانوا مهتمين بهذا الشيء
ولو في نفس الوقت ما عرفت كيف حسين
يقتنع بهذا الموضوع كانت موجوده همم
راسي فرجات وكده وعملت اتفاق اني اكتب
مقالات واني اخذ المقابل هنا وهنا
وطلعت شيء ثاني بعض من الاغاني كانت جيده
في الفتره هذه لا لا ههه
كتبتها يعني
لكن
عارف من اللي غناها من اللي ههه بعرف
قعد سته شهور تقريبا
لحست عاجل يعني بس كيف باريس ما كنت عارف
كنت حاسسني عنصدم بالمجتمع بس اي تنصدم
يعني
طلع الحب كل باريس المدينه
[موسيقى]
يعني
طول اليوم وانت تغدي هذا
مخك بهذا الارض افكار جميله في كل مكان
قصه لكل يعني كل كل
متجر عنده عرض واحد نفسها هي كانها تحكي
قصه فن كامل
يعني في منطقه اسمها سان جيرمان هذا
المنطقه
لو تقعد من الصباح للمساء هيمر عليك 20
نوع من الفن من الموسيقى
فيدعموا حتى مختلف اكثر انه يعتبرون انه
بيعاني في منطقه معينه
فحتى تسهل لي اشياء كثيره
ما هو مقبوله اني ادرس الموضوع
طبعا جاري دعم كثير من عندهم انه يا هذا
لازم نعمل له نساعده على شان يبني شيء في
البلد او ابن يشيل الفن خاصه في الموضوع
بدا في باريس طبعا همم
تغير شكل الدراسه ترى شكل التكنيك تغير
شكل
كان عندنا تاريخ الازياء كان مهم
دراسته مهمه جدا لاي واحد يدخل الموضه
لانه تعرفك على تاريخ الموضه من بدل انسان
يحط هذا القش الي وصلنا الى حالتنا هذه
كانت ممتعه اكثر الدراسه في باريس
وكنت في نفس الوقت خايف اشي نهايتها
يعني ايش نهايه
فكرت انه خلاص اعيش في فرنسا او ابقى
فرنسا يعني انه ممكن لكن
جاءتني عرض عام 88 من الاكاديميه اني اكون
محاضر
وكانت
كانت بالنسبه لي هي اول مره اشعر بالغرور
في حياتي
يعني انه طالب الى محاضره
في العربي كلاجرافي في الخط العربي كيف
ادخله في الموضوع
يعني كانت كانت بالنسبه لي اقول لك كانت
غرور عجيب ماني مصدي نفسي اني وصلت لهذا
الشيء وحتى
زوجتي واولادها في الاكاديميه فكنت فهي
اخذت عندي درسي ولكن ما اهتميت فيها انه
لما قالت لي انا اروح السعوديه من عمري 12
سنه عشان اختي هناك
فكرت يعني في الموضوع كده
وكانتي بدايه ان هي انا ثمان شهور او تسع
شهور يدرس تقريبا وبعدين خلاص بدات افكر
اشتغلت معها
حوالي ثلاثه شهور بعدين حسيت اني دائما
وقلت لازم ارجع اقدر ابني من بلدي شيء
ولكن معركه الصعوبات والهذا بس لو قعدت في
الظل الحضيه في الظل طول عمري لو جلست
اكون في الباكستيج ودائما اصمم كنت تصمم
للبنات الشرق الاوسط
بس ما في شيء باسمي هو يطلع كل شيء انا بس
تفضل مالي علاقه
قلت ما اقدر ما يمكن تكون في بلد هو ينتج
الموضوع وعنده هذا الكم من الناس انك
تنافس او شيء ما تقدر
منها شيء ولكن مدام حياه كلها مؤامرات
وانا كل حياتي
ممكن تبني نفسك اسم همم
بعدين
يشتروك من دار الازياء هذه كلهم كده لما
تكون عند كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
في مكان لمده 20 30 سنه بعدين تيجي شركه
تقرر ما تعمل باسمه اوكي
[ضحك]
بس
وبدات لنفسه لكن لما تبدا تحت حد ما تبين
[موسيقى]
هذا الكلام
مواصفات صغيره يعني عدد كبير هنا كثير
تعتمد على عدد اقل
عدد الناس
يعني
بدايات بسيطه وعلى
متواضعه ولكن بدات اعرف بدل الناس يسالوا
عني
اييي منين طبعا المفاجاه الي تفجرت مع
الليدي ديانا هي اللي غيرت
المعايير كلها
قبل ديانا في هذيك الفتره
حسيت انه انت تسوي
نفسك يسمونه
بس انه اوكي تقدر تعيش وتقدر ما بعرف اصلا
[موسيقى]
والدنيا وكنت عارف انه مع الوقت كل ما
نعرف اكتر او ينزل لي اعلام او ينزل لي اه
طبعا كان الحلم هو عرض ازياء بس انه يبان
امكانيه
وانه السعودي يشتغل في الازياء كانت زياد
ولا غير مقبول
يمكن مثلا عند اهل جده الى حد ما مقبول
يعني ناس كانوا اوكي يتفاعلوا حتى نتكلم
على خاصه جانب الرجال
اه
ومؤيدين الى حد ما لكن
اي شيء من المملكه المناطق المملكه
الثانيه انا لما اقول
حديث يسالني ايش تشتغل دائما اقول بصوت
منخفض مصمم هذه عشاء لانه في البدايه لو
قلت
طيب اسف اسف غلطت يعني
انه زمان التاريخ
اخته وامه خالته وفي الاخر
اوكي
الشاطئ في التصميم يعني يعني كنت اميل
لهذا الشيء
ولو لقيت فرصه واحده تلبس بحريه وهذا همم
ما كانت كنت هفضل الازياء غير محتشمها
طيب طيب
كل اللي مع النسوان
متى اول مره يعني بعد بعد فرنسا حاولت
تقول لاهلك انه الوالد مثلا
في نفس الفتره يعني تقريبا لما بدات خلاص
صار عندي محل وهذا وعرف ما كان ما كان
متفاعل يعني
[موسيقى]
سويت محل نسائي وازياء بس ما اعرف ايش
الفكره ما هو مثلا يعني ايش تصميم او انه
كيف
يعني لا اعتراض ولكن ما كان حابه شيء يعني
عارف انه كمان
[موسيقى]
انه كان طول عمره مع النساء
ههه المغامرات كثير الحين همم برده في
الزواج ابو كرار الرافق اه لا وافق همم
شلون يوافق عليه اخذت موافقته كيف قتل
والله
ما كانت مسلمه
وكان يوم الجمعه وبعدين قعدت ارتب الكلام
وبعد الصلاه رحت لما شفت نسيت الكلام كله
ما عاد عرفته فرنسيه
[ضحك]
قلبي جالس معي انه كده انت كل شيء تسويه
مدري ايه ضد الكلام لكن خلال نص ساعه
الله يعلم انك تحبها
بس عندي شرط لازم تسلم
[موسيقى]
موافق الوالد ما اقدر اكمل
هذا الشيء الوحيد اللي كنت رابطه موافقه
تبوك
الرضا الديني
والتقاليد والمعرفه
كانت مؤثره بشكل كبير يعني لو رجع الزمان
ما ما عملت فيها اشياء كثيره
بعد عرض ازياء باريس من شركه في نيويورك
احلى عرض في حياتي مره وكان هذا في
التسعين هذا اللي كان ممكن يغير حياتي
الثاني
انه جاني عرض عرض كبير يعني مبلغ كبير في
هذاك الفتره
وقال لي
دخلت انا في الشغل
فرنسيه وسكتنا باقي هذه الهجره انا برضاي
عليك
الحين افكر فيها برات يعني فطبعا خط رضا
ابويا انه اهم بس اعتقد انه لو رحت
نيويورك كان احسن له
يعني هذا هيكون رضا اكثر
وكان مستقب اكبر ليا طيب نحن المره المرور
بطل الاحداث يعني
الاشياء الدينيه بالاشياء التقليديه
بسرعه
حتى لو انك تعرف انه مستقبل هذا جيد وانت
تقدر تعوره
لكن
اللحظه بهذا الشكل مع الزمان مع الخبره
ايجابيات الطرح
يعني
اثر
عليك كثير
ما عندي علاقه فيه انا بعيد عنهم لكن من
خلاله كان التاثير يعني كانوا ينقلوا له
كل الصور الخاصه يعني لو تعرف مقابله بشكل
معين راحوا يقولوا له همم يعني حتى هو فرض
علي شيء في الزواج انا ما تزوجت في
السعوديه تزوجت في مصر
فطبعا اهلها عشان يحضروا اجدادتهم معه ما
كان في اختلاط في السعوديه فقلت اعمل همم
الفرح في مصر يعني بلد محايد بين اهلها
واهلي
هو قال لي ابوي على شرط شوف لا شوف لها
صوره في مكان في مجال ولا جريده
طيب في يوم الفرح لقيت التلفزيون المصري
واحد كتب مقاله في الاهرام انه نجم
الازياء السعودي
[موسيقى]
وجمعوا له المجلات الطيبين
يورونا يعني طبعا
لمده طويله
[موسيقى]
رئيس استفادوا في الاخير قلت
يعني
بس كلام
يعني بعد فتره تغير ورضي عليه
انه بعد هذا الصور شويه كانت الازعاج وانا
عارف انه الضغط اللي يصير عليه انه دائما
يتكلم
[موسيقى]
في الديره
بس بس
لو بس يتوضا في وظيفه ما عجبتهم
يضغطون على الواحد
بس في الاخير شوف ما يصلح الا الصحيح انا
اقول لك شيء كل هذا النقط اللي كان يجيني
وكانوا يعترضوا عليه وكانوا يعتبروا انها
راعي ومبادي في هذا الان صارت مطلب لكل
احد هي المساله مين يبدا من يتحمله انا
دائما اقول
انت لما تفتح الشباك على مكان مغلق اكيد
هتجيء لك ريح ويجيء لك همم
اثار وخدوش هذا لكن فتحت الباب هذا المهم
لما تفتح باب
همم لا تتوقع انك تحب همم عارف هذا الشيء
لا اتوقع اني اكون
اه يعني استقبلوني ان استقبال فاتحين كنت
عارف انه حيصادم كثير يعني كنت اعرف كنت
اجي انزل مطار جده بعد اي عرض ازياء على
طول على المباحث من المطار
من المطار كانت كده كل عرض اعمله على طول
على المباحث وتبدا التحقيقات ولا ذوي
ايقافات ومع انه كيف تقدم هذا الشيء وانت
سعودي كيف تقدم الازياء هذا يا جماعه انا
اقدم باسمي لما انا اقدم باسم السعوديه
اختلف الموضوع انا دائما العمل
في ناس كثير تعبوا عشان هذا المشهد يوصل
بهذا الشكل
اللي في الموضه اللي في الشعر اللي في
الادب اللي في الرسم اللي في الغناء كلهم
عالوا مثلي يعني مو انا اللي بس كنت اعاني
كانوا كلهم اصحابي وعشان كده هذا ما سهل
لما اقعد معه مطربين لما نقعد مع شعاع
شعارات كتاب رسامين تشكيليين انا نفس
المعاناه كلهم لقوها
فهذا الحراك اللي عملناه هذا المدى الطويل
والصراع مع هذا المتشددين والصراع مع
الافكار
اللي ما تساعد على التطور هذه بلد هي
تراكم حضاري لان بنت الان المشهد اللي انت
تشوفه وصار اسرع
ما تنسى همم
والله انا عندي مواقف كثير لكن الموقف
الغبي
اللي اعتبره غبي منه مره جوني
وقالوا طلبوا حضوري
ايش السبب قالوا احنا من سنتين نتابعك
واللوغو حقك مثير او
لازم هذا اللوجو انه يتغير او انك لانه
مثير
مثير للجنس عندهم ممكن
المشكله
طيب قال لي انت اصلا التغريب اثر عليك
انا قلت والله طيب عشان المطلوب مني قال
لي انك توقع الان ورقه تعهد انك تغير وقت
قال لي حتى توقف وتوقفني وقفني بعدين ثاني
يوم ما لقوا بسببك
قالوا انه تعلم في امريكا فقلت يعني جيد
ممكن نلاقي له مخرج معه
قال قلت له يا اخي انا اللي يعرف الاسلام
انه دين اوفوا حضاره يعني معقول لوجو يطير
رجل الدين طب ليش شاف البنطلون ايش يصير
لو حطيت بنطلون ايش كان ممكن يصير
طبعا حلت المشكله من هذا الناحيه ولكن
كانت واقفه معهم كثير
اقول انا كنت من ضمن الناس الي يحاربوا في
هذا الموضوع كان كل واحد يقدم بشكل معين
في مجالله واعتقد انه ناس كثير ضحوا اشياء
كثيره في حياتهم وتصادم واكثر حتى علينا
عائليه لانه عنده مرات يدخلوا حتى على
العائله يعني يوصلون لو ما نجحوا مع
الواحد
يوصلوا العائله ابنه كده ويعطونه وصفات
غريبه
هذه اللي عندهم حتى
المانيا
ولكن هي وصف بشيء اسود من كده طيب انت
تقول انه تفصيل
فستان ديانا كان هو نقل نوعيه في حياتك
لا هو نقله في في مستقبل المهني
لكن هي ما تلبس المصممين الانجليزي
المهم كمان انك تلتقط
اشياء صغيره عشان تنجح يعني ما يكفي انك
تكون موهوب
لازم يكون عندك العلاقات جيده لازم عندك
تواصل مع الناس سيد ولازم تلتقط الاشياء
والفرص تجيب غرابه او انت تصنعها انا
تقريبا شفت
لما الصحابه الايطاليه هاجمتها انها ليش
لبست ان رفضت لبس مصمم ايطالي
وفي نفس الوقت وانا في شغله في جريده
الشرق الاوسط نهائيه وشعر زي السعوديه
كلمت السفير بريطاني وقلت اني انا مصمم
ازياء وابقى اسوي
ما ما عنده فكره عن الموضوع
قال لي اكتب خطاب ونشوف
انا كتبت الخطاب بريطانيا
وحتى الصياغه
الانجليزيه مختلفه لما اتكلم
وكيف نعمل
كده بعد 15 يوم كلموني السفاره من الاميره
موافقه بس شوف التصميم يمكن هذا الحيره مع
نفسي ثلاثه ايام اربع ايام وانا ادور طيب
ايش اسوي لها اذا العالم كلهم
بس
رجعت القريه في راسي
اللي حلت الازمه
وبالمصادفه اليوم هو معروض في الرياض في
نسخه منه معروضه في الرياض اليوم
بسعر العمل
وسلمت العمل ونسيته سلمته
[موسيقى]
يعني
بس اشوفك
[موسيقى]
اولا
بدات الطلبات علي بشكل غريب من كل مكان من
الكويت من هنا من معرفه
وكان عندي مشكله كيف احط السعر انا متعود
على لساني صغير طيب كيف ارفع السعر
الثاني
[موسيقى]
يعني بدات ثقافه ثانيه بس كان هذا ميزه
الجمع المالي هذا ومع الخطاب اني ارسلت
النقابه الموضه الراقيه في باريس
في اسبوع الموضه في فرنسا عند شروط صعبه
كيف تدخل لازم
تجي لك دعوه من مصممين من 16 دراسه او
نقابه الموضه تعزمك على هذا الحال او ما
احد كلها لانه في شيء اسمه
داخل قائمه
خليني اشوف ايش يصير
محلاكي يعني مش سهل
الموافقه على شان خطاب
فتحت الباب ومن الفلوس اللي على
الدعاياتها جبتها صرفتها
وكان هذا العرض الاول اللي يشكل لي شكل
الانتحار الاول في باريس
[موسيقى]
الموضه
مسيطره يعني كلها شركات عالميه كبيره
حوالي 15% من الاجزاء العراقي ما يمكن
يخلونه احد يعبر بسهوله بس ما بتعرف
عرفت من اللي يسوي فيه
والله يمكن على هذا العرض اغرب شيء ممكن
يصير انه
اعتقد انه خلوني لان قبل العرض ب 20 25
يوم لقوا عندي
السبب بدون اي سبب
بدون
خلاص
جات لي صدفه انه في صاله
والصاله مرضيه تعطيني في الوقت هذا ورجعنا
النقابه ووافقوا في الاخير ااااه كانت
الصعوبه الثانيه انه لمن دخلت الازياء من
جده الملابس طلبوا شيخ مصدق الجمارك وما
كنت تمتلك المال
فكان هذا خلص الحلم كله انت اللي عشته هذا
قالوا لي ترى السفاره السعوديه ممكن لو
اعطتك خطاب
احنا نوافق عليه بس
رفضت انها تعتبر
مسؤوليه جوازي عندكم لغايه ما المسؤوليه
ما اعرف هم قالوا بس الجمارك اعطنا خطاب
انك ما تبيعها هذه القطع انك ما تبيعها اه
في السفاره تقول انه تعزيز فقلت جوازي
عندكم
[موسيقى]
بس يمكن يبون 200000 فرنك كم هذه بالريال
يمكن او 200 الف يمكن 150,000 ريال
مصدق ماهو الشيء بس عشان يضمننا لا تخرج
يعني الحال
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الاكتئاب وانا في البيت
اتصل فيه قال تعال خذ الملابس
صديقه عارضه كلمت واحد صاحبي مصطفى الشاعر
طلع كتب لهم الشيك
وراجع العمل وصار العمل
يعني بعد
اكثر من محطه كانت عشان كدا سميته كان هو
انتحار لانه انت تحارب لوحدك بدون دعم
الليمون الفرنسيه تقول مره ثانيه همم
تقول على مدى 20 سنه ويقدم الدعوه
للسفير السعودي باريس لكن الدعوه تبقى على
مكتبه
ما عمرو حضر
رامي يا جدي عرض تكلفه عاليه حضور اعلامي
كبير طاير عالميين ودعايه لهم وما يدفع
ولا شيء بس لو اخذ 50 دعوه
وقدمها للفنانين وسياسيين اضافت شيء بس ما
كانوا
لانه لانه
المتشدد
ويخاف يكون موجود
[موسيقى]
حطيت الموسيقى
مع لوحات تعطي وهي تغني باليماني بشكل
وبرده جيت للتساؤلات هناك كيف تحط مغنيه
يهوديه ومعرفه يعني الصراع ما ينتهي في
الفن اا صوره العرض
رجعت الجده ايش كان وضعك وقتها الان ما
بعد ديانا بعد اسبوع
في حياتي صعب على مستوى الصحف العالميه
على
همم معظم المجلات العالميه
وركب طائره خاصه لاول مره
هذا اول مره في حياتي اركب طائره خاصه هذه
نقل لهذا العرض انه طائره بالجنيه في لندن
هنا تغيرت معادلات كثيره في حياتي انه
يعني ما كنت تفكر في حياتي
كل الازمه تغيرت المشهد هذا كله انتهى
ولما شافوا صور الملك والاشياء اللي انا
عملتها له وكلمين في ساعتها
بعده
عماد
التراث السعودي وخليك مع النساء دخلك في
الرجال
[موسيقى]
الملك عبد الله الله يرحمه
الملك عبد العزيز عبد العزيز الله يرحمه
كان عندي كتاب اسمه صور الماضي اوريك ابوك
[موسيقى]
قال لي والله شيء حلو بس الان احنا في عصر
البوليستر في افقر عصر في لبسنا بوريك
اللي يسويه
كلها زينه وراء هالمره عليك قلت والله ما
ادري هذا رايها قال لي لازمني منها كلها
من هناك تغير المشهد تغير الهده ومن بعدها
سنه تقريبا
كيف كانت اول تكليف
كان الله يرحمه في المغرب وانا كنت في
باريس وقالوا لي تعال قال لي السنه
الجنادريه الجنادريه هذه السنه كان الف
عارض او راقص وكانوا سبعه مطربين
فكانت اكبر عمل مسرح
والاكبر اني كنت
غيرت النمط انه حاولت ادخل الجنوب مع
الشمال
[موسيقى]
ممكن
الخلفيه كنت معرض الضرب في اي لحظه
[موسيقى]
لبس من تصميمك
ولما كلفني اول ما سوى العرضه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
كلها دجلات هنديه اقمشه هنديه ما فيها
يعني
والتاثير الهندي
المملكه كيف ادخل الزخرفه السعوديه
يعني حتى اتذكر الملك عبد الله كان يقدم
لي ملك البحرين ويقول له انه يشوف شال
الدجلات الهنديه وهذا بدخل انا كلها ااا
طراز الجزيره العربيه
ااااه
من هنا انا فتحت باب للناس في الموضه فتحت
للشباب للبنات انه
نحن هذه مقبوله وهذا كان تحدي الكبيره
عندي بالاول اني محترمه ترى صناعه موضه
كامله بس ما كان هذه اقنعها يقتنع يعني
كانوا يعتبرها يعني الديونيه يكلموك او
شيء لما شافوا الملك بيتكلم بهذا الطريقه
او يعني لهذا العمل
دخلوا البنات والشباب في المجال وساروا
يتفاخر وساروا معرفه فحسيتهم
والاثار اللي اخذتها بدات تعطي النتيجه
[موسيقى]
وبالنسبه لاهل
القريه تغيرت نظرتهم بعد المدرسه
متواصل مع القريه بشكل كثير ما اعرف يعني
ما اعرف اشي نظرتهم لي ولكن مرات اشوف
تويتر
والله يا عم صالح اذا بتشارك ما عندي مانع
قام كلم اخو عبد العزيز
فقلت كيف اطول ازاي هذا كيف اعمل شيء
اعمل له اضافات تجميليه لانه موجود
قائم انت مجرد
عليها اشياء تجميليه المصمم اكبر من كده
يبتكر شيء غير موجود
فانا نحط هذا تحت هذا اللاين انا اعتبره
تطوير للثوب اكثر من اني اعمله تصميم
يمكن اللي عملت التغيير
لاني دخلت قماش المشكله بتفكير مختلف انا
الي حكمنا نظفت في الثياب اني دخلت
الاقمشه الطبيعيه اللي لون الفيسكوس
الاقطان يعني اللي بعيده عن
الاقمشه كلها كيماويات يعني اه
بعدين هسه وين عرض ازياء جدا اول مره اسوي
عرض ازياء جدا في الشارع همم
الرجال السعوديين اللي سوى الموسيقى سعودي
انا المصمم وسوينا كلنا نتين مع بعض 97
وكنا كنا همم عندي صديق في الداخليه طلبته
من انه يحميهن يحط لنا سيارات
وعد العرض بسلام وهم عنده في في شارع بين
بيوت
وهنا كتبه علينا
التغيير الاول او التحول في المجتمعنا
في الخير
اعطاني المال اعطاني الشهره اعطاني
الصراحه هذا كله اشياء كثيره وتمتع فيها
يعني
ما اخر همم الاشياء هذه
يعني مثلا في الجزيره
العربيه الجزيره
العربيه اي قماش تعطيه هديه وشيء يحولوا
لهذا اللبس وفي الاخير هم هم
مزارع او شيء علاقه بالانتاجيه الابيض
مع التطور مثلا القماش نفسه صار ثوره في
العالم يعني العالم كان من اقمشه كان
يصنعها باليد الى الثوره الصناعيه لان
داخل البوليستر لان دخل يعني كميه
التكنولوجيا اللي تاثرت فيها الاقمشه فهذا
البوليستر سوا
انتاج على مستوى غدير وباسعار رخيصه من
هنا حولوا تكلفه السعر غاليه الى الاسعار
رخيصه دخل عندنا البوليستر
تغير النمط في الحياه سعره يقتنع انه هذا
الثوب الابيض هو اللي يعكس الحراره والشمس
انا قاعده اولا يعني انا استغرب ليش ما في
كل الوقت
ليش دائما ابيض ما انت تشتغل في المكتب
وانت معك اجانب لابسين بدل صوف
ايش الفرق يعني ليش ما لبس الورد يعني ليش
لازم
الوان طيب
سعاده تضيف حالك
يعني الذكر واشنطن بوست كتبت عني مقال انه
اول من وضع الالوان في خارطه الثوب
تيجي تقول لا بس الابيض
في السياره مكيف
بس هي في الاخير هتغير لانه نظره الجمال
او الالوان تضيف جمال على الحياه
طب ممكن تكون
جاءت غيرنا حين الان الثوب السعودي الان
هو مقدمه قميص ايطالي او فرنسي يعني في
عندنا بالقميص الفرنسي في تويتا
بالكويتي
او
بدون بدون
انه تطور يعني ما سمعت في العالم
كيف دخلت اني هل تطوره
الاقمشه مع سهوله الاقمشه اللي تدخل
انت اول ما كان عندك هذا الشيء ما كان
عندك سرعه
ناس واحد جاب قميص لابسه وشاف الثانيه
ابغى زيه بس هي التطوير يجي حتى من الناس
زمان ما في الا ميديا ولا في عروض ازياء
ولا شيء كانت الموضه
انت تجي مثلا من اندونيسيا وتيجي على
السعوديه لابس لبسك فيعجبنا لبسك
بالله اعطينا منه تكون تتحول الى تاجر لها
ويصير نلبس او تيجي عندنا وننتقدك ما تقوم
تلبس لبسنا كانت تتحول موضه بهذا الشكل
طيب قبول الناس للتغيرات 97 في البدايه
كانت صدمه يعني
ما خرجت كثير يعني كانت الاضافات كنت اضيف
همم صديري او الاضافات الدقله الدجله اللي
خرجت فيها بشكل اكبر ما تكبره في البدايه
كام بالنسبه
وبدات الاوصاف والسب يعني يحطوا تسميات
يعني ليه نسوي لو كنت استمع لها كان
انتهيت من زمان ما كنت اعبرها لما اللبس
الملك عبد الله تغيره كلهم
دائما كنت اقول دائما القائد السياسي هو
المحرر للتغيير
سبع سنوات
وكلفت كما ااا عام 2010 كان برضو هو يمكن
اهم اشهر عرض عملته في حياتي برده كان من
الملك عبد الله تكليف انه كانوا بيسووا
ااه معرض في كنتاكي للفروسيه واسمها هديه
الصحراء
سويت عرض ازياء
مستوحه علاقه الانسان بالحصان
وكان حوالي
130 قطعه رجال ونساء وعملتها على شكل
مسرحيه
فهذه كمان يعني كانت دعم كبير انه وهي
موجوده القطاع
اغلب الناس في السعوديه يعني الكل
في الاخير كلاسيك كلاسيك
المشكله
الرئيسيه الناس
كل اختياراتنا في الحياه في ما كلنا في
مشروع ربنا في ملبسنا في سكننا لازم نعطي
للناس قيمه كبيره اذا تخلصنا انت حر تبغى
تلبس تبغى تلبس باضافه واللي بغيت يتميزهم
دائما يتميز لسه تطورت
هي اصلا ما كانت متطوره
وانا اللبس الاحمر لون قبيح للرجل
قهوه
لابس قميص احمر
[موسيقى]
اوكي بسيطه تعودت عليها طول السنين هيصبح
جزء
الازرق لو قعدنا 20 سنه ما شفنا الا
الازرق نفس الشيء هي العمليه
تعودت عندي حوالي عندي 10 تصاميم للجماع
لكن كلها قريبه من بعض لانه عندي اعاقه في
التمثيل المصانع محدده بهذا الطريقه
مهبوله بهذا الشكل معين ما تقدر تغير منه
فلذلك كل التغيرات اللي يضيف الخط يزيد
بشكل معين غير اللون شويه بس ايش اللي
يخلي همم
اهو كل مصمم ازياء عنده مجموعه رخصيه
اعطيني النظارات اعطي لا احتياط
الشماغ اعطي لاي شيء في اي اكس سريع اعطيه
بس يستوي المواصفات يدرس شيء المواصفات
ويعطيهم المواصفات ما تنزل عن كدا ولا هم
بيسمعوها في منهم يصنعوها في فلسطين
بالنسبه للنساء العبايات تاخذ يعني بعد ما
كانت سعوديه
يعني
في مكان مخلوقات بهذا الشيء ومغصوب عليها
اني لازم البسه
يعني معايا في الاخير هي حره تبعت البس
عبايه وتلبس عبايه هذا يرجع لها هذا
قيمتها او هيزيد انا اعتقد الانسان هي
بعلمه باخلاقه بادبها باحترام المجتمعات
ااا الوان هذه خلاص هي زيها زي الثياب
عشان كده لازم كاميرا ثياب كثير زيهم لازم
تتنافس مع المراه ههه نفس الالوان طيب
حاول تدخل العبايات ليش لا ما احبها ما
تحبها اااه حسنا
يعني ما ما اقدر اوصف بس احس انه
مغصوبه غصب انت فعرضها بالقوه هي مخيار
يعتمد على المجتمع في كثير من البلدان في
كثير من المناطقنا اااه لا يمكن تكون خيار
عند في الرياض عند البنت اللي متعلمه
واللي من اسره
يقبلوا اهلها الكفاهم ولكن
غالبيه الاسر السعوديه ما يقبل التفاهم
اااه انا حسن
تعجبني العبايه وتعجبني اي شيء اذا كانت
اختياريه اي شيء يصير فرضيه اعتقد انه
غير مقبول كيف طيب تشوف تصاميم لعبه في
السوق
اللي ماخذه على شكل الجاكيت الطويل
[موسيقى]
اه اليوم اختلف المشهد ان مشهد كذاب صحيح
اليوم عندنا هيئه ازياء عندنا هيئه زياده
سوت برامج
لو تطبقه 50% منها
هتكون نقله كبيره في الموضه عندنا حاجتين
لازم لازم نكون واقعين شويه ونترك الحلم
يعني همم انا اللي ما اعترض عليه ان احنا
نوازي انفسنا
ببلدان لهم مئات السنين في هذا المجال
ونبقى نقول نروح زيهم اذا نبغى نوصل وننجح
في الموضوع لازم نؤمن باكاديميات تعليميه
اول شيء لازم نحل بنعلم عشان نطلع جيل
مهني انت كيف تسوي صناعه موضه وانت ما
عندك اي مقاومه عليك
مع النافس ولا نقدر هذا لازم ننساه انه
نعتمد على التصنيع في اي مكان نجاح الموضه
يعني مثلا لم تتكلم على نيويورك نيويورك
ااه تقريبا هي عاصمه
الصناعه الموضوع بس معفنه
هي تنتج براندات
تسوقها تعرف كيف تعرضها وتشهرها
بس ما تسالها في اي مكان الصناعه اروح
للمكان الارخص والعالم كله يتنافس سعره
انت عندك المصاريف او عندك تكلفه عاليه ما
تقدر تنافس في التصنيع اذا هذا اختلف اي
مشكله لكن كيف ندعم
الموهوبيندات
لازم تعرف انه في الموضه فيها 35
وهذه 35 مهنه فيها الرواتب واللي ياخذها
كلهم اجانب معه السعوديين والسعوديات غير
موجود
كلمات انجليزي
[موسيقى]
عندك الايه كوميرس كل التجاره الالكترونيه
عندك فن العرض
يعني 35 مهنه رواتبها كلها عاليه وكلها
كلها تشتغل في الصناعه فكل الكبار هذه
المحلات التجاريه كلها المتاجر يحتاجون
هذا الناس بس يبون متعلم عشان لما تعطي له
فالنهارده في المحل فن البيع لين يصير
براند مانجر
[موسيقى]
هو اذا تعلم هيحب ويعرف انه يكبر لما
نجيبه كده وتقول له اقعد هو يقعد ثلاثه
شهور بس عشان ينقل وظيفه ثانيه فهو بس
داخل مؤقت لانه ما يعرفها واذا انا جيت
عند واحد انت لو تروح عند واحد الان وتقول
والله ما ادري
نسبه القطبيه
الغسيل كده
انت هتسلم مؤامره هتقول له طيب ايش تختار
لي
فن هو اذا وصل هذا الشيء يصير مدير مبيعات
يصير الحلم عنده من التعليم انه عشق هذا
الشيء اذا لازم اعمل اكاديميه
عشان هذا الموهوبه اللي تصير لانه مصمم
بدون هذا الموهوبين
جامعه الاميره
البلد
لا يمكن لا يمكن
اه عشان كده لازم نركز على جوارب
بلاش نعطي الناس الطريقه همم
طريق خطا للتعليم
هي الاخيره
ايش في مشاكل ثانيه في المشهد في المشهد
لازم
موهوبات وعلى شان يسووا صناعه
مدارس شباب
لازم هيئه الازياء تعمل مع
مع مكاتب وزاره العمل عشان تجيب الهدول
البنات اللي بداوا بعمل او شيء نعمل لهم
مساعده في المصاريف تكاليف لهذا اللي
ياخذونها على العام انهم يعفوهم عنها او
اي شيء عشان
يقدروا ينافسه ويقدروا يعملوا شيء لانه ما
يقدر يتحدوا بهذا الشكل يعني الصنعه عندهم
بره ارخص تيجي هنا تلاقيها خمسه سته اضعاف
كيف بتشوف التجارب الناجح مثل العجلان
مدام دخل عندي يعني مثلا
[موسيقى]
التسويقيه
اكيد انه لازم ترفع الطاقيه لهم تحترمهم
هذول اللي نجحوا هو ما نجحوا فراغ العلمي
وجاب مستثمرين عشان يساعدونا في هذا الشيء
واقتنعوا المستقبلين في اداءه تحتاج ما
اعرف عن البنات ما ما شفت البنات كيف
تجاربهم
اه نحتاج دعم رجال الاعمال انهم دائما
يعطوا هذا المواهب
مكانه عشان يقدر يفرزه انت تشوف مثلا
اليابانيين كيف وصلوا الى اوروبا وامريكا
كله بتعمل رجال
عندنا متاجر كبيره الموضه
[موسيقى]
في ناس بيختلفوا عليهم فاهمينه
يعني مرات يستغرب يقول لك طيب ليش السنه
هذه اللون كدا
اخواني رحنا
في يوم اعجبني اللون انا مالي علاقه باي
شيء قولي لي لا ما ينفع ليش قالوا هذا
الترند سنه
هذا يعني
رجل يعني همم
مجموعه الوان
لكن على كلن خلينا نقول حتى الاستاذ
دائما ترند يبدا من صناعه الاقمشه
الاتحاد الاقمشه لصنعه يجتمعوا على ان نحن
السنه
نحط خمسه الوان تيم وبعدين مشكله الموضه
ما حد يعرف فيها الازياء الراقيه تختلف عن
الازياء الجاهزه عن الكاج والعن سبورت
خطوط كثيره مثل مختلفه يعني
وحتى لما يجوا يقولوا ليش ما وصلنا هنا
المصانع في العالم مرات مصنع القميص يختلف
عن مصنع البنطلون عن مصنع التنوره كل مصنع
مختلف تماما عن الثاني
اه بعد كده يعرضون هذا الاقمشه مثلا لو
قلنا فيها يناير هيقدموا لبس الصيف
من هنا المصممين يجوا يلتقطوا هذا الالوان
ويبدا وينعرف الترند انه هو خمسه وسته
الوان للريدي توير او للسهره او
فالناس كثير يعتقدوا انه مصممه
هو دائما يبدا من الاقمشه لانه كمان عند
صناعه الاقمشه عندها مصممين اقمشه
فهي اللي تبدا منها
فانا انا كنت اتوقع انك ترند يبدا من
الناس اختار هذا الشكل لا لا تبدا من هنا
وبعدين
في عروض الازياء بعدين تبدا تنتشر طيب
اليوم في اكثر من يعني العلامات والبرندات
السعوديه كثير اليوم اا فحتى يعني في
نيويورك
فواضح ان في دعم حكومي للبراندات يعني عكس
ما كان سابقا لكن كيف تشوف اليوم يعني
عندك
يعني ما معنى ما يهمني مياه
الناجحين يمين اثنين
يعرض عليهم
الدور على شركات عالميه انهم يشتروا يعني
تحطي ميه او شيماء
[موسيقى]
يعني كم انا انا مش نظري في العكس ولا
الصحيح
كان المفروض بالمبالغ والارقام الي اصرفها
هذه اني اسوي هنا في السعوديه
في وقت معدات اسميه اسبوع
150 60 ما تفرق كل واحد يقدم الي عنده انا
علي عشان ادعمكم في البدايه اختار هذا
الصاله وحطوا الفلوس
عدد الباير اللي جوه شافه وعجبهم هم
هيعرضوا على هذا المصمم هو المصممه انه
دائما التجار عيونهم في كل مكان اذا عجبهم
اااه
طريقه طرح احد منهم اكيد هيعرض عليها
الشراء هنا يبدا النجاح انك تنطلق من
محليه العالميه
كنت في مهرجان بحب احمر
لبس الرسمي السعودي او همم
لبس البدله
فيظهر لي كده كانه دائما انه اذا انا بطلع
كشخه اني البس بدله ليش ارتبط هذا الشكل
عشان كثرت كله
بشيء ثاني جديد فهو يحاول هذا الشيء اعتقد
لو انه هذا الاسبوع
السينما او هذا المهرجان السينما في
ايطاليا وانت السعوديه اكيد هتلبس ثوب
لانك هتكون مختلفه
هو انا عارف انه دائما كل الناس
اشياء كثير لكن او تقدر تضيف اضافات كثيره
انا شايف كم واحد لابسين من عندي من
الدقلات المفتوح
همم ويسترن اكثر يعني يعجبوا هذا الشيء
ولكن الحريه الموضه مالها حدود ممتاز
البيست والملح
ارتباط فقط بالاشياء الرسميه فقط يعني
تلقى السعودي ما يلبس الا في يمكن يوم
زواجه وما هذه الاستاذ يوم ثاني هل هذا
طبيعي ولا مفترض انك لا لا طبيعي
حتى في الزواج هذا يتعافر ما يعرف يلبسه
يعني يحطه يمين يحطه
انا انا طورته
تقدر تلبسهم حريه فقدتك واخذت الارض اللي
موجود وعملت بطريقه الدكتور
هنا يعني انا اتذكر اول فرح واحد اقنعته
انا كنت كيف بدات لبس الرجالي كنت ااه
عادي ما حد يبغى يلبس هذا فلما انا الاقي
سفير واحد يحس انه يلبس كده اقول له خلاص
خليك سفير ليه
كل شيء اسوي لك شيء بس عارف انك هتنقل
الصوره والبشر فواحد اقتنع انه في زواج
يلبس ثلاجه
شيء اساسي
ما هو ما هو مريح الا اللي متعود عليه
اللي يلبسه دائما وفي مجتمعهم على طول
في ناس بعض الناس يناموا بكره فهذا ما
عندك مشكله
[ضحك]
شوف الاخير الجمال
المراه على الرجل فلما اخذ هذا الفرح قريب
وشكله
ما التيار كله مغيره يلبسه كده اول اللقوه
الصوره تطلع حلوه مشيته ما عنده مشاكل
فانا اشوفها افضل
وكيل مشلح الرسمي
راح حكوميه او طريقه طبعا يعجبني عندي
طبعا حتى تجربه في ال في المسبح كانت
انا غيرت المشكله
ومين اللي يسوي هذا النقوش احسن فرحه
الاحسن
وغيرت النقوش وطلبت اني اعمل هذا النقوش
طبعا طالعوا فيه قلب مجنون ولا
يلبس هذا الشيء يا اخي انا بسوي نفسي
كل يوم زي بعض
قلت له انا ابغى اسوي لي هذا الشيء
قال لي شوف هذا
هنقعد نطول فيها علشان شيء جديد ما
اتعودنا عليه ولكن بقول لك شيء بسوي لك
اياه واذا احد لبسه لك خمسه هديه
قلت له طيب يعني اعتبر اني انا مجنون واني
قاعد اجرب شيء وان الناس تقبل هذا الموضوع
النقوش الجديده اللي عملتها مين اول واحد
يلبسه الله يرحمه الشيخ احمد زكي ماني
عم احمد خليني اصور اصورته
للحساوي سوا لي خمسه بلاش
طيب ليش ما بدنا الى الان احنا السعوديه
[موسيقى]
طيب ويجامل منه لكن
لطيف ولا مو لطيف
لكن الثوب ما يتصدر بس انك تقدر تصدر
ازيها تقدر تعمل شيء من الثوم تقدر
تستوحي من الازياء من الازياء اللي موجوده
عندنا بنقدر استوحي منها هذا ممكن وانا
اتوقع انا دائما اقول اذا
مصممين لازم ياخذ
الهام حقه من منتجنا راح يكون غريب هيكون
مختلف يعني لما تقدم شيء من القط طالما
تقدم شيء من النقوش نجد من المصمك
فيها تعقيدات كثير لذلك نفس البسه واحنا
نلبس العالم يلبسها انت واحد ذحين تبغى
تصدر المنتجنا هذاك يصدرونه العالم كله
وكل العالم واحد متوحد على لبس معين كل
العالم متوحد على اللي اسمهين انت جيت
واخترقه تقول لك لا البسه
مايك يعني الا اذا صرت على نفس التكنيك
يعني انا عامل عرض ازياء عام 2006 للرجال
باريس عرض في الاسبوع الماضي وباريس
استوحيط من الشماغ استوحيد بس عمل جاكيت
واخذ منه اذن مثلا نزله بقطعه صغيره هذا
اللي تقدر تاخذه انك توصل لهم شيء من
ثقافه
[ضحك]
يعني يحطون ممكن انك تصدرهاك
الطويل
تصدرها الا ممكن للمجتمع الاسلامي ممكن
المجتمع الاسلامي عشان كده انا يوم من
الايام
حجتي بس ما لقيت همم
محافظ لبس محافظ
مدام انت في في انا درست المراه السعوديه
في مجبوره
وفي اختياريه
المجبورين كثير عددهم اكثر من اختياري هذا
المجبوره
كيف اقدم لها شيء
انيق وولام يحاكي الموضه وعملت على انه
فكره كامله
تختار اكثر من قطعه كود طويل بشكل معين
وتنسقها كلها مع بعض بالوان ويكون فيه
جانب الميك اب الخفيفه اللي ما يبين
والبير فيهم اللي ما يعطي اذا كنت تعملها
كانت زوجه رئيس وزراء ماليزيا بس تبعد
تحطه تحت مسمى اسلام
انا قلت لها الموضه ما تصلح انك تحط
تحديانات خلي ديانات شيء
لو
تكلمنا مع الحكير وكانوا داخلين في الفكره
وما انا ما كملت ولكن انا اظن في العالم
الاسلامي كله يحتاج
زي محافظ براندات محافظه هذا الشكل على
المستوى العالم الاسلامي بتتكلم بليز
اندونيسيا تركيا ايران دول الخليج مصر
المسلمين في اوروبا في امريكا عدد كبير من
النساء الغربي
وخلاص كانت الفكره هتبدا
منتشره في كل مكان
اي لا لا والله فكره رهيبه يعني فعلا يعني
سواء في العالم الاسلامي
محافظين موجودين الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا
لك شكرا لكم شكرا يا عبد العزيز المزيوي
مدني في الهندسه الصوتيه وهو موسى في
التصوير وجميل عبد الاحد في التحرير
وتنجيد العطاس في التلوين
وساعد في الانتاج الاصيل طفرت هذا فنجان
احد منتجات شركه الثمانيه لانشر التوزيع
نشر كل الانتاج من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل